Luke and Jake here with the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel and we're here stranded
in the Alaskan Peninsula and we're
spending the next three days camping
avoiding Bears foraging for food
exploring abandoned Villages and the
only way we're getting home is by bush
plane
[Music]
where he is
hope to make it through the night
all this time you thought would never
pay the price
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
let's get our stuff we gotta go do some
hiking
all right guys welcome to poly Creek
Alaska now Polly Creek is located on the
northeast part of the Alaskan peninsula
[Music]
an Alaska Peninsula is known for having
the highest concentration of brown bears
anywhere in North America tourists from
all over the world come to the Alaska
Peninsula to see a brown bear but unlike
them our goal is to not see a brown bear
hopefully that'll go smoothly
foreign
look at the size of this wolf I mean
that man that is huge look at the length
of his gate too
dang that's a big wolf
but no bear prints that's good
come on Jake let's go explore a little
bit
looks like a piece of Jade right there
if he makes jewelry out of that
check this out this is pumice we're
really close to mount readout and mount
spur which are two of Alaska's more
active volcanoes when I was a kid Mount
spur erupted and dumped several inches
of volcanic ash on our house there's a
little scream
[Music]
yeah it's a little brackish
check this out
this is a shell of a razor clam it's a
large edible clam it's really common out
here
so we could kind of scout these mud
flats out and see if we can find any
mud flats we have a 20 to 30 foot tide
here in Alaska and we also have
quicksand
it's a really nasty combination
oh I cut into a yeah where is he oh
there he is this is kind of like a blood
worm or a ragworm
these little piles of sand poo that's
from those worms those worms make
excellent bait for certain types of
ocean fish all right check this out
this is a shell of a butter clam one of
the many edible clams here in Alaska
these are mussels they always attach
themselves to rocks those are also tasty
and edible but those ones are pretty
small we'll leave them be low tide was a
couple hours ago and the Tide's coming
in pretty quick so we can't stay out on
these mud flats much longer I'm just
kind of Scouting Around seeing if I can
find a good place to come back and Hunt
clams
here's a bunch of those worm piles
oh check this out
these right here are cockles another
great edible clam here in Alaska I'd
love to find some of these I mean I'm
looking around and I'm seeing shells all
over the place I think we're in the
right area I'm looking for little
dimples in the sand to let me know where
the clams are hiding now look at that
see there's a little hole in the ground
right there so we're gonna do is go and
dig next to it
oh there he is see him
oh little baby razor clam
you want to eat them for dinner okay
here you hold on to him he's you're your
responsibility oh look at that time's
coming in so fast Jake see look how fast
the Tide's coming
that's going pretty quick should we get
out of here
you can see this is where we were
walking just a few minutes ago
the water in this channel has gotten a
foot deeper in just 10 minutes
all right let's get out of here well we
found a spot to clam tomorrow but not in
the moment too soon
all right all right let's set up our
tent we're gonna need Big Sticks
all right Jake found some good sticks
because I got a portable electric
grizzly bear fence we're going to set up
around our tent
yeah it should be on
all right we're gonna take a little bit
of grass and we're gonna test this as
you get closer
you can feel it go beep beep
beep
all right it's off
all right got the tag completely set up
but look at the tide
man it's come up there was 10 foot
Boulders out there and I can't even see
him anymore here you hungry
let's see what we got for snacks here
would you like some trail mix
[Music]
we got Lehi movie gummies
I've got some figs and dates and cheese
and crackers
it's all right
now we got camps up and food in us we
need to go find some fresh water
there we go barefense is on that'll keep
the wolves and bears out of our food
look at that that's a cool shell we
gotta find a whole one of those for
mommy my wife's love language is
seashells
oh look at this
that is a pretty piece of quartz look
how clear that is
this is a commercial fish camp where
commercial clam diggers will stay during
the summer to dig clams they got this
big refrigerated Conex they put their
clams in there that gets ships off to a
processing plant
but I'm not 100 sure if this place has
been abandoned or not
yeah there we go fresh water
what do you think about this bridge Jake
I've seen some sketchy bridges in my
time this one Takes the Cake I'm not
sure I want to be on that I'm gonna die
sometime but it's not going to be today
on that bridge
there's the Otter's Footprints and there
there's his tail a lot of stuff going on
here
oh is it is it
oh look at this look at that mommy's
gonna be so happy there's shells all
over the place
oh that one's cute that one's not broken
at all
that's a nice one
oh
I can see 11 sea otters just right over
there floating on their backs sea otters
love to eat butter clams
uh-huh
there we go man this weather has turned
out wonderful well I think we need to
gather some firewood we're gonna be here
for three days and we want a big fire so
we're gonna need a lot of firewood
yeah
there's a seal right there his head's
sticking out of the water
he looked real curious about what we
were doing
there you go
you want
Hey Jake you hungry
I think Jake's gonna have the lasagna
and meat sauce I'm gonna do the spicy
gumbo
I got some bread flour and yeast mixed
together I'm gonna make some bread
did I get it
okay all right
there we go
looks like the Tide's starting to go
down we're gonna start getting our
second low tide here in a couple hours
thank you
let me put your coat on yet I think it's
time to cook up this clam
these clams are really easy to Shell
gonna season my clam with a little
pepper
now I'm going to roll them in a little
pancake batter
take a little oil
there we go
right I am definitely okay catching some
more of those
Jake do you like your lasagna
did you know sometimes I
think
we're gonna have some fresh bread with
my gumbo here
I'll tell you what these dehydrated
meals are a whole lot more tolerable
when you have fresh bread to go with it
yeah that makes a difference
now that we got dinners we need to go
get some water you ready Jake
yeah all righty
what
let me see you
all right
oh he's so fast I'm tired oh it's not
out
all right you ready for some chocolate
milk
or
steak
that's good stuff isn't it double thumbs
up Devil's thumbs up you like that
yeah
don't get stabbed by the knife
now you want to see a special s'more
this is Hershey's chocolate sauce you're
gonna take this off
oh look at this there's just more
okay we got the little we got the little
hole in the marshmallow
fill that up with chocolate
hmm
Tide's kind of getting out there I think
me and Jake might go out and explore a
little bit more
he's walking a straight line
it's nice yeah look at that that's in
good condition
there we go that is a perfect razor clam
dimple if you dig straight on them they
cut you can break them so you dig right
next to you
ah there he is
there he is
there you go a little one there's one
right there see
you know
there he is right there
yep there he is
yeah we got him when he was trying to
escape us
you found one that is one good job Jake
you want to dig him hold on look at that
there's one right there we go
hey look right there right there hold on
I'm gonna go right in between these two
there's one
oh
look at that
dude there's two in there
look at that that was easy to spot him
why there's another one not for clan
whoa do you see that he squirted at you
if he tried to pee on you there we go
there you go that that's a big one let's
see that
the battle
we found a bunch of razor clams but
they're all kind of small and tomorrow's
our big negative tide so I gotta find a
better spot to clam come tomorrow
morning
if I can get it
there we go much and they don't have
holes in them oh that's a lot better
isn't it well Jake I think we better get
you to bed we gotta get up early
tomorrow for the tide
nope
there you go y'all tucked in bud
I'm gonna go and clean up the camp a
little bit okay
everything's packed up Jacob's asleep I
think it's time for me to do the same
all right guys I'm gonna see you bright
and early tomorrow morning
now they got a fire going I can get
Jacob up
Jacob
you wake up buddy you got a nice big
yeah
well Jake this is a really big tide I
think we might find some big clams you
ready to do that
all right I brought a clam gun it sucks
the clams right out of the mud a little
hole right there got the dimple right
here
put your finger over it
whoa and there he is
you want to dig
[Music]
there you go that's a decent sized
dimple right there
oh look at that finally finding some
proper size razor clams
[Music]
there we go
that's a good one Jake
oh look at that that's a big one
[Music]
foreign
you hungry you want some lunch
all right
a little bit
I think Jacob's a little cold and wet I
think it's hard to get him in the tent
Ed it down grab your blankie and when
you're done with your Mac and Cheese
just put it outside the tent so it
doesn't spill
you like that yeah good all right I'm
gonna have a very Alaskan delicacy here
gonna have some hot Tang
hot Tang on a camp out it's very
nostalgic
well me and Jake are fed but we are wet
and cold so I think I'm gonna hunker
down in the tent with Jake and hang out
for a little bit
Hey Jake you want to watch a movie
together
why
Red Alert all units
you want some cheese and crackers
[Applause]
we've been watching lots of shows and
eating lots of snacks but I think it's
time for me to go outside and clean some
clams what do you think
I'm gonna pick out all the crushed clams
and I'm gonna clean those and eat those
tonight
so this is what the clam looks like
outside of its shell this is the foot he
uses it to dig down and this is the most
tasty part this is the siphon it's got
two tubes in it and it sucks in water
filters out the food and spits it out
then you've got the skirt which is the
part that seals the clam shell shut and
then you've got the guts with the siphon
you just cut this little dark part off
and then you run your knife down the
siphon both tubes and you open up the
siphon so you can get all the silt out
all right
thank you
stick them near the fire to keep them
warm and clean
Hey Jake welcome out
yeah come out here here sit next to the
knife nice to not be rained on anymore
hey Jacob do you want some clams
yep all right
hello
salt pepper and pancake mix that's all
that is
I don't think you would get very far you
know why
here you go
you like that
well
oh he's trying to get away
hello
where Asian clams are delicious but they
have a reputation for being rubbery the
key is to cook them quickly you want to
cook them for seconds not minutes
oh
I gotta go refill the water before it
gets too late tonight
hey I got a question for you
would you like to see me shoot the gun
yeah
oh
I'd make a nice Target
all right Jake you think I can hit that
shell
you're getting fired
Hey Jake what do you think was that cool
yeah the seven millimeter Magnum kicks
like a mule now my dad gave me this gun
when I was a teenager I haven't used it
in like 20 years but hopefully this this
fall I'll do some hunting with it all
right Jake you want to roast some
marshmallows Justice
but we
is that one yours I'll eat it if you
don't
and then it's lava rock chocolate lava
oh here let me see a little bit of that
marshmallow
just
I need that my selfie stick tripod broke
so I'm going to take some of your
marshmallow here and I'm going to use it
to fix it
actually works pretty good there we go
fix my selfie stick with marshmallow
thanks Jake
welcome over this would you like to hang
out by the fire a little bit
with your blankie
oh you're getting so big
you get snuggled in there and go to
sleep and I'm gonna go get the campsite
cleaned up a little bit okay
well Jacob's asleep and I've got a few
hours before my bedtime so I'm just
hanging out here by the fire
[Music]
I got every word
perfectly way too
honest
would it change yeah this has been an
absolutely beautiful spot
really enjoyed this but if all goes
according to plan today is our last day
here but I do think I'm gonna break down
the bear fence I don't need it while I'm
awake
foreign
yeah Jacob's jacket's a little damp so
we're gonna just hang it up to dry oh I
am so glad the weather is nice right now
it's miserable trying to pack up in the
rain
all right it's weird I'll admit it
but fried spam and instant oatmeal
actually goes really well together
let's see if Jacob wants to get up
hey Jacob I've got breakfast for you
oh quick oh
projects
okay okay
down here
way out there in the mud flats the boat
just ran aground it's a clam fishing
charter these Charters will come here
when the tide is falling and run aground
and the tide will leave the boat all
high and dry people get out and clam dig
and once the tide comes back in they get
back on the boat the boat floats and
then off they go
all right there we go
all right we gotta walk back to our
Rendezvous point
oh
[Music]
Hey Thomas did you guys have fun you
like the flight yeah
if I live in your thoughts
about you all the time morning
and midnight such a wonderful Delight
[Music]
for gold
give up everything that I own yeah
[Music]
of course
yeah
well guys I hope you enjoyed this video
if you want to see more videos from the
outdoor Boys YouTube channel don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every Saturday morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching